mesdames et messieurs bonsoir on va leur
faire on va leur faire on va le faire
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir c'est bon
la pause a été bien tranquille vous avez
pris votre esprit vous êtes ressources
et ça tombe bien moi aussi je vais très
bien je suis très heureux d'être parmi
vous ce soir de pouvoir partager ma
vision des choses en tant qu'athlète
sportifs artistes enfin comme vous
voulez c'est vrai que j'ai plus
l'habitude de communiquer autrement
aujourd'hui ce sera avec les mots je
vais relever le défi mais bon en
attendant je vais me présenter je
m'appelle c'est anne garnier
j'ai 31 ans j'habite à paris et je suis
double champion du monde de football
freestyle triple champion de france de
football freestyle est champion de
france de futsal or j'en ai vu un euro
et la diola attends je suis perdu je
reviens de pose de qu'est-ce qui se
passe tranquille je vais t'expliquer si
on prend le mot freestyle freestyle
style libre liberté d'esprit
en fait vous voyez du freestyle partout
tout le temps tout le monde freestyle
il ya des trucs plus catégoriques comme
le ski freestyle le skate freestyle
palais des sports bmx freestyle mais en
fait on peut freestyle et avec ce qu'on
veut on peut freestyle avec son corps on
peut freestyle et avec une casquette
merci il a oublié pas grave on peut
l'applaudir
on peut freestyle avec une casquette au
plat moi aussi j'ai oublié je peux
mettre ma casquette ou pas ça vous
dérange
je la mets non oui c'est bon parce que
c'est pour casser les codes un petit peu
ça fait partie de mon personnage
mais en fait le freestyle avant tous une
étape c'est un état d'esprit
c'est une façon de penser c'est une
façon de s'adapter c'est une façon de
s'exprimer et moi dans ma vie j'ai
trouvé ma façon de freestyle et ce avec
un ballon est-ce que je peux avoir mais
voilà il n'a pas oublié
merci donc moi je reste avec mon voile
on voulait voir c'est pas assez si vous
êtes ça je vous montrerai plus tard donc
je reste avec un certain nombre mais
pourquoi t'es pas jouer au football
quoi tu joues au foot bah en fait les
sites joue au football j'ai passé par
les centres de formation de auxerre 2-3
j'ai été blessé longtemps et ce qui a
fait que j'ai pas réussi à être
footballeur professionnel
mais d'ailleurs pourquoi le foot il est
ensuivi du monde entier pourquoi tout le
monde suit le foot pourquoi lie à l'euro
et tout le monde est en sang sur le foot
pourquoi en fait je pense et c'est ma
façon de voir les choses que juste le
ballon c'est accessible à tout le monde
qui n'est pas descendu en bas de chez
soi à jouer au ballon avec son pote fait
des passes tiré contre un mur
s'amuser à lancer la balle à la main on
peut jouer avec tout le monde et le pire
le plus important c'est que quand on se
rend compte qu avec ce ballon si on le
maîtrise on peut avoir
l'admiration de tous ses amis toute sa
famille on se rend compte que c'est
parlant il a un pouvoir c'est exactement
ce que j'ai réalisé un jour en étant de
qui j'ai réalisé qu'en en trois jours
mon père il était comme un dingue
il s'y est montré à tous ses amis vas-y
fais des jonques fait des jambes j'ai
dit c'est très bien il suffit juste que
je maîtrise ce ballon et je vais avoir
le respect de tout le monde je vais
avoir la reconnaissance des gens donc je
regardais de dessin animé olive et tom
olive et tom vous connaissez voilà
olivier atteinte c'était moi j'ai pris
un ballon je partais partout avec mon
ballon je m'entraînais à l'école les
profits devenait fou j'ai décidé de
m'entraîner tous les jours et ce ballon
j'ai été j'ai eu la chance d'être
recrutée à l'aj auxerre à l'époque de
guy roux est bon c'est vrai que dans un
cadre football c'est un peu différent
c'est que les il ya beaucoup de règles
est aussi tu change d'endroit autour de
toi c'est plus tes amis autour de toi
c'est plus ta maison et aussi autour de
toi tu es plus si spécial parce que moi
j'étais spéciale avec mon ballon chez
moi on arrive en contre des mecs qui
sont aussi forts plus ou moins fort que
toi et plus si spécial étant une
personne de nature timide et de nature
introvertie
c'était peut-être compliqué pour moi de
m'imposer dans un monde footballistique
et de me faire comprendre
j'ai réussi à aller jusqu au monde
roh à m'entraîner avec les pros à 3 et
des blessures on enfants autrement et ça
a brisé ma carrière ce qui s'est passé
ensuite
c'est que je suis venu sur la région
parisienne et j'ai décidé d'être
éducateur sportif et 2 et devenir avec
les jeunes
enseigner le football est ce que je me
suis rendu compte c'est qu'il ya des
jeunes qui était très doué au foot et
qu'on les mettait toujours en avant mais
il ya tous les autres jeunes on les
mettait jamais en avant je me suis dit
je vais créer une session d'entraînement
où les jeunes pourront faire ce qu'ils
veulent ils avaient le choix de jouer
avec le ballon mais tu joues avec autre
chose et je me suis rendu compte que
plus de la moitié
il joue à d'autres choses il joue à
danser il joue à chanter il se hissait
taquiner entre entre les deux et c'est
que ce qui était fort au foot qui
continue à jouer au foot mais les autres
ils chercher d'autres façons s'exprimer
je me suis dit ok si je leur fais
quelques gestes savez les amuse et j'ai
commencé à faire quelques gestes de
freestyle et m'ont dit faisant ils ont
continué à me demander à faire de plus
en plus des gestes
j'ai compris
que le football auquel je joue en étant
petit c'est celui qui plaisait donc je
me suis dit je vais devenir freestylers
j'ai commencé à me balader à paris et
j'ai vu des danseurs haut en bas de la
tour eiffel faire des shows et un rond
de malades autour d'eux avait de la
musique qui jouait tout le monde
rigolait hier je peux faire la même
chose avec mon ballon je vais essayer de
rentrer dans le cercle j'ai commencé à
jongler aucun emplacement personnes il
ya un problème
en fait je me suis rendu compte que
c'est vrai que dans le monde du football
faire quelques gestes ça de la
signification
à partir du moment où tu rentres dans un
autre monde l'autre monde a ses propres
codes
en fait je me suis rendu compte que
chaque place c'est comme un nouveau pays
c'est une langue c'est une culture et
que moi mon moyen de m'exprimer c'est
avec mon ballon mais qu'il fallait que
j'apprenne toutes les façons de
s'exprimer chaque différentes places
avec ses danseurs j'ai appris à me
comporter sans ballon j'ai appris à
exprimer avec mon corps j'ai appris
d'autres choses que je n'avais jamais
appris dans le monde du foot parce qu'on
parle tout le temps football 2 endurance
dans ses shows de rue etc
j'ai eu la chance de participer au
championnat du monde il y avait les
meilleures photos certains des meilleurs
footballeurs de la planète
edgar davids bebeto falcao un des
meilleurs danseurs ce qui a fondé la
danse hip hop crazy legs est en fait
j'ai eu la chance de gagner ce
championnat du monde
j'ai pas gagné parce que j'étais le
meilleur j'ai gagné en fait simplement
par le fait que j'essayais de comprendre
les codes de cette compétition
et comment communiquer avec les gens
qu'elle aime regarder comment
communiquer avec les juges
comment communiquer avec l'audience
comment un communiqué avec la musique en
fait comment rendre chaque élément
autour de toi et communiquer avec lui
pour pouvoir que ça fasse un plus gros
résultat
j'ai fait ça et ça m'a ouvert les portes
mais le premier obstacle que j'ai trouvé
c'est qu'à partir du moment où j'ai
gagné j'ai eu les caméras qui sont venus
face à moi what do you feel after his
victory un jeu maintenant anglais moi je
me suis dit il ya une limite dans ma
communication chez communiquer avec mon
ballon mais je ne sais pas communiquer
autrement
donc mon prochain challenge c'était
comment communiquer avec les gens de
façon différente mais avec la voix avec
l'attitude avec les gestes et j'ai
appris en voyage endurance et en ayant
les opportunités de chose de pouvoir
communiquer avec les gens aussi par la
parole donc j'ai appris l'anglais
n'était pas à l'école c'était en
voyageant et c'était la meilleure
expérience j'ai appris tout
son communiqué justement grâce à ça
ensuite d'ailleurs voulais voir ce que
c'est un petit peu un show de freestyle
vous êtes sûrs ou pas je protège jusqu'à
3 vous allez faire un match et mazaury
1-2-3 fait du bruit au hockey dj tu peux
lancer le son se te plaît
oui
ce
car si à tout ça vous a plu vous en
voulez encore moi aussi
non c'est là c'est le genre de blagues
qu'on fait dans les street choquant en
galère donc c'est un peu de jours de
dialogue qu'on avait d'ailleurs dans le
public j'ai entendu ça sert à rien sur
un terrain qui a 10 à 6 personnes
bon je vais appeler le meilleur
footballeur de la salle il est où il est
où les eaux il s'appelle didier attend
il et on va le chercher
allez hop ça va être toi on peut faire
du bruit pour lui alors c'est très
simple tu vas essayer de prendre le
ballon et si tu le prends tu vas mettre
un petit pont as-tu la pressée de mettre
un petit pont dj avant la musique
on peut l'applaudir
allez pas dire ça alors next challenge
pourquoi j'ai fait ça parce que chaque
fois que je faisais des show de
freestyle j'entendais ça sert absolument
rien sur un terrain du coup moi en tant
que footballeur j'ai été piqué donc je
me disais il faut que j'arrive à
renverser la tendance
ce que j'ai fait c'est que j'ai pris mon
ballon et j'étais à prêt à affronter les
meilleurs footballeurs de la planète
neymar zidane
eden hazard malouda toutes les vidéos
que j'ai pu faire sur internet ont fait
un buzz ce que j'ai essayé d'apprendre
aussi et comment maîtriser les réseaux
sociaux
comment maîtriser les outils qu'on me
donnait à disponibilité comment faire en
sorte que les gens sachent pas seulement
qu'il ya un freestyler avec des prêts ce
qui fait des gestes de fou avec un
ballon que aussi il y a quelqu'un qui
s'appelle céline garnier cas une
histoire et il ya aussi d'autres
freestylers dans le monde qui font cette
discipline
ok donc ce que j'ai fait j'ai défié ses
joueurs de foot et en fait on me disait
mais comment ça se fait que tu arrives à
mettre entre guillemets à l'amande
neymar alors que il pourquoi tu joue pas
au foot en fait c'était très simple à
comprendre
imaginez un joueur de poker est un
magicien tous les deux jouent avec des
cartes peuvent que le mal le joueur de
poker il joue à un jeu un jeu ça avec
des règles et cartes c'est juste
l'instrument du jeu le magicien il prend
les cartes
il sort du jeu du poker et devient un
technicien de la carte c'est exactement
ce que j'ai fait j'ai pris le ballon
puis sortie du jeu du football et je
suis devenu un technicien du ballon rond
c'est ce que j'ai essayé de faire est en
fait c'est pour ça que je suis capable
de faire des gestes techniques
c'est à dire que les jeux les joueurs de
foot ne s'entraîne pas la technique avec
le ballon qui s'entraînent juste à jouer
un jeu
ce que j'essaie de faire c'est
simplement de banaliser tout ça et
transmettre mon art au plus grand nombre
comme j'ai fait avec vous
on essaye de reprendre son souffle
voilà je voulais je voulais finir par
trois choses à la base je m'appelais
arnaud garnier
donc c'est un peu moins sexy je sais
voilà j'étais quelqu'un d'introverti
timide et mon seule façon de communiquer
c'est avec ce ballon je me suis
transformée en c est pourquoi c and sean
paul
j'ai transformé ans et anne la première
fois que j'ai fait un show je me suis
fait pas on a cru que j'étais un
brésilien je parlais pas français
j'ai dit l'asie appelez moi ces années
on verra comment ça se passe j'ai
construit un personnage mais en fait ces
années arnaud c'est la même personne
c'est juste que c est ni la droite de
tomber et droit de faire des fautes et
surtout ils avaient envie d'apprendre
plus je faisais des choses plus j'avais
envie d'apprendre et cet apprentissage
cette ouverture d'esprit
elle a permis d'avoir toutes ces
expériences et toutes ces choses que
j'ai pu accomplir
donc voilà est la dernière chose que je
vais dire si je voudrais rendre un
hommage à quelqu'un disparaît
aujourd'hui mohamed ali qui était un
grand champion et qui a dit if i want to
be a great things i hate you believe it
is here are not l'état de new york
merci